هذه الصورة التي أعرضها على شاشتي هنا
هي لمدينة تسمى فوز أركنساس ، لقد
كانت أعاصير قوية للغاية
مرت للتو عبر جنوب شرق
الولايات المتحدة ، إحدى البحيرات الموجودة في كاليفورنيا والتي
تعاني بشكل رهيب من ظروف الجفاف ، فإن
سد النهضة الإثيوبي الكبير يرى القوة  من
المياه القادمة عبر هذا هو أوكرانيا شبه
جزيرة القرم على وجه الخصوص نحن
نشاهدها ونشاهدها ونحصل على
سجل فوتوغرافي لبعض
الأشياء المذهلة التي تحدث في جميع أنحاء العالم ،
صنعت شركة Maxar للأقمار الصناعية اسمًا
لنفسها على صور مثل هذه
المشاهد المكشوفة  من الحرب في أوكرانيا ، مثل
احتشاد القوات الروسية بالقرب من
الحدود الأوكرانية قبل الغزو ،
وترأس هذه القافلة الروسية
العام الماضي صور الأقمار الصناعية الرئيسية المقدمة إلى CNN والتي
أظهرت القصف المكثف
لخطوط الأشجار والحرب في أوكرانيا.
الفرق
هذه الصور الكاشفة غير العادية
قريبة جدًا وواضحة جدًا قبل وبعد
تكشف صور الأقمار الصناعية عن دمار غير عادي ،
فهذه منطقة على طول
ساحل البحر الأسود مباشرة حيث
بنى الروس التحصينات على طول
الشاطئ ، وهذه هي ما يسمى
بأسنان التنين التي يتم استخدامها  لمنع
الدبابات أو المركبات العسكرية الأخرى من
التحرك إلى الشاطئ ، وهو مرة أخرى
انعكاس لنوع الأشياء التي
نراها قادرة على الدوران والرؤية من
فوق منطقة كبيرة جدًا ولكن بمستوى
من التفاصيل يصبح مقنعًا للغاية
ومفهومًا بصريًا للغاية.
لديها عقود عملاء في جميع أنحاء العالم
بما في ذلك الحكومات وتشارك
بياناتها مع وكالات الأنباء مثل CNN ،
هناك قدر لا يُشبع من
الطلب في هذه المرحلة على الخدمات المستندة إلى الموقع
لفهم ما
يحدث على كوكبنا المتغير لدينا
نقاط ساخنة نذهب إليها  للمراقبة
لأننا نعلم أنها
أجزاء أوكرانيا المهمة من عواصف كوريا الشمالية في
الغرب الأوسط ، يمكنك تسميتها حرفيًا كل
90 دقيقة تقوم الأقمار الصناعية
بتمريرها ، وبينما
تدور الأرض ، نجمع المزيد من البيانات ،
يعد maxar واحدًا من عدة
قمر صناعي خاص  الشركات في الولايات المتحدة مثل
Planet Labs black sky و isai
وأول من حصل على ترخيص Enterprise
من حكومة الولايات المتحدة في التسعينيات
لمراقبة الأرض التجارية من الفضاء في
ذلك الوقت كانت الشركة تُعرف باسم
worldview Imaging ، لقد
فجرنا بالفعل أول زوجين لدينا
الأقمار الصناعية وكان ذلك
ماء باردًا في وجهه ، حيث كان الفضاء
صعبًا ،
حصلنا على صورنا الأولى وكانت
مدهشة لأننا كنا
نرى أشياء حول العالم
كانت بمستوى من التفاصيل
لم يسبق لمعظم الناس رؤيتها من قبل اليوم ،
هناك أكثر من  قام 90 maxar ببناء
أقمار صناعية في المدار ويمكن للشركة
جمع 3.8 مليون كيلومتر مربع من
الصور عالية الدقة كل يوم ، هناك
دائمًا شيء يحدث في
مكان ما في العالم ، ومع ذلك فإن
ما نفعله حقًا هو المساعدة في إلقاء نظرة على
الصور وتحليلها ثم ترجمتها
حتى يتمكن الأشخاص من فهم ما
نراه ،
تبيع maxar أيضًا أقمارها الصناعية في
التكنولوجيا ذات الصلة وتعمل على تطوير
طرق جديدة لجمع البيانات من الفضاء بما في ذلك
التحليل ثلاثي الأبعاد ، تخيل مستقبلًا حيث
تحصل على كل شيء رقميًا
بتنسيق ثلاثي الأبعاد وهو توأم  لما
يحدث فعليًا على الكوكب ، يحدث حدث
يشبه كارثة طبيعية أو إعصار
يمكنك اكتشافه بسرعة كبيرة حيث توجد
مناطق سهل الفيضان حيث
قد يتأثر الناس حيث توفر
أفضل وسائل الإغاثة أفضل السبل لإجلاء
الأشخاص أو تقديم الإغاثة الطبية و
أعتقد أن maxar ستكون في
طليعة ذلك أننا نجعل هذا
النوع من المعلومات متاحًا
عالميًا ونقدم مستوى من
الشفافية العالمية لم يكن
موجودًا قبل أن يُسأل غالبًا عن
جانب الخصوصية فيه  لا يمكن رؤية
الأفراد والقدرة على
التعرف على هويتهم إذا كانت هناك
أشياء يحتمل أن تكون موضع شك ،
لدينا عملية مراجعة داخلية ولكن
بشكل عام المزيد من المعلومات هي
مجتمعات حرة جيدة تزدهر في
توافر المعلومات لاتخاذ
قرارات مستنيرة ونحن  جزء من
تلك
[الموسيقى]